allez là il a beau festival un festival
de cannes façon entre vous et lui c'est
une grande histoire d'amour vrai non non
non ce sera en tout cas je suis très ému
d'être là de retourner au cinéma ce film
en compétition aussi c'est merveilleux
hyper émue et heureuse
et puis c'est symbolique d'être la
préfecture j'avais envie d'être évident
alors les intrants qu'il est en
compétition un film de joachim la pause
que jouer au côté damien bonnart un
sujet difficile la bipolarité vous
morflé dans le film le couple sur sur le
couple si oui gens moches mais il ya
énormément d'amour c'est un film c'est
un film qui compte énormément pour moi
et je j'étais hyper heureuse pour que
j'ai super été sélectionnés je suis très
ému et très fier de la compagne et son
fils mati diop à ladite à l'heure que
c'était pas le 64e festival de cannes le
premier de la nouvelle ère car c'est ça
on en est là on est dans ce reboot leur
lancement allez je vais rejoindre
matthieu diop et ouais pouvoir aller ces
premiers jours
les premières années du festival de
cannes merci leïla